hello it's been a while hmm I looked
like a k-pop member before his plastic
surgery yeah oh [ __ ] Oh what is going on
you two
it has been a while my friends you
missed his face yeah I know you didn't
now every year as we know it
Thanksgiving comes around and every time
this holiday is around we'd like to talk
about what we're thankful for
now I know this [ __ ] has passed but
let's talk about this for a second uno
momento por floor uno momento portable
huh okay
sound like Count Chocula and [ __ ]
wouldn't now I think I speak for a lot
of us because even though a lot of us
say that we should be thankful most of
us aren't most of us are ungrateful
[ __ ] because every year the youtubers
that you watch puts on some emotional as
music in the background and does the hey
guys every time a youtuber wants you to
do something positive they got to put on
this face and say hey hey guys it's
Kwanzaa hey guys it's Christmas hey guys
it's Buddha's birthday why don't we
should see I'm not gonna tell you guys
how to be thankful mmm none of my
business but here are a few reasons why
you should be thankful and for you to
stop ruining it for everybody else so if
you know some negative people is time to
shove some positivity all up in the face
open wide a sugar pop titty all up in
that's a lot dirtier than I thought it
would but you already know what it is
LGI baby let's get it let's go man quit
yo negativity let me ask you something
how many times is a Stephen come around
here one time and you go ruin it for me
job angry make Dookie face every year I
wait for this holiday to roll by and you
know why because I get to eat a [ __ ] ton
of food and I get to see my family and
before you say [ __ ] yes I eat a [ __ ] ton
of food on a regular basis but when
Thanksgiving comes around I'm not alone
in my room in a wife-beater in my boxers
all ho and you ever noticed that every
negative person on Thanksgiving always
likes to mention what the real
Thanksgiving is really about how
horrible Christopher Columbus was how he
came over about smallpox and mastered a
whole bunch of Native Americans let me
tell you something here Ditka Pina
we
get it look we don't need you to tell us
every year that Christopher Columbus was
a colonial douche we already know that
and guess what the [ __ ] is dead you
think anybody's just around talking
about how great Christopher Columbus was
huh is that what you do on your face
Stephen that's for you done it dear God
thank you for the crazy white man who
got lost as [ __ ] at sea like I said he
messes up he gets a holiday I'm [ __ ]
falta monkey [ __ ] and you know what else
I hear a lot [ __ ] I ain't got nothing to
be thankful fo you have nothing to be
thankful for
let me tell you something here you
little wrinkly ball sack you're not
looking hard enough
I'm gonna list a few things and I'll
take before just to show you how
negative you are I'm thankful for my
[ __ ] eyeballs that's right why
you ask my little booty stayin so I can
see myself walk up to you and hug the
[ __ ] out your face yup and then I can
watch myself go to jail because you
probably think I'm sexually assaulting
you which I'm not I'm just a stranger
trying to force my love package on your
face that's right I sound like a sex
offender well however cliche it sounds
I'm also thankful for the fact that I
have a roof over my head you know why
because I cannot be homeless so I'm very
grateful that I get to wake up in a bed
and in a house with some running water
let me tell you something nobody's
sucking no dick for money over here nope
ain't doing that chop that [ __ ] up so
fast you know people who aren't very
thankful you know what happens more
often than not for some reason we always
like to look at what other people have
to reiterate what we don't have and my
friends in all honesty that's not a way
to live trust me your whole life you are
going to be miserable if you constantly
focus on what you like personally and
materialistically listen don't take what
you have for granted and don't hate your
life because you don't have when others
have be positive and hate them instead I
go sit around and hate yourself love
yourself take somebody else that's what
Isis
you ever feel so broke did you make
somebody rich feel stupid for having
money ladies [ __ ] over here with the
Ferrari what you got help
oh you got gloves babe I'll need a love
I just use my hot ass breath like this
look life is too short to worry about
what you don't have
so just remember for next year take that
negativity away and learn how to be a
little bit positive
so before I start off everybody have a
Merry Christmas
is it merry Thanksgiving I don't know I
wasn't born yet I was born in Korea I
don't [ __ ] know all right
happy the man in the Christmas of
Thanksgiving huh hey what is going on
YouTube now check this link below now I
decided to be a part of a campaign for
audible.com now if you guys don't know
I'm actually a huge fan of audiobooks
and for me it's something that I listen
to while I Drive in the car rather than
music sometimes so what audible.com is
offering is a free 30-day trial for you
guys to cop a credit where you can grab
a free audiobook and after that through
your paid membership you will be given
one credit per month to go ahead and cut
yourself another audiobook which is a
pretty sweet deal the first audio book
that I downloaded was the power of habit
by Michael doing for me it's a pretty
dope weed is kind of about harnessing
your habits to work for you so check out
the link below the icon on the side and
the link in the description to go ahead
and copper free audiobook on your 30 day
trial so my past Thanksgiving gift to
you guys is this free audiobook trial I
got it I loved it
and you all know me I love things that
are free oh my god the Sun sets so
beautiful
Saiki anybody care god damn it if I see
one more [ __ ] sunset picture I'm
gonna [ __ ] kill myself I'm gonna do it